FIVE."
"SPECIAL REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
>> Bret: YOU GUYS HAVE A LOT
OF FUN.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
BREAKING TONIGHT, WE ARE GETTING
A RULING FROM A JUDGE, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DONALD
McGAHN MUST COMPLY WITH A
HOUSE SUBPOENA ACCORDING TO
COURT RULES.
A RULING JUST IN FROM A JUDGE,
THIS IS A LAWSUIT FILED BY THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THIS COURT IS COMPELLING FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON MCGAHN
TO TESTIFY IN THE HOUSE.
THIS IS THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS
GOES FROM THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE TO THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHEN LAWMAKERS COME
BACK, AS HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL BE COMPELLED TO
ESSENTIALLY WRITE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
IT.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE WITH HIS
RULING COMPELLING FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL TO TESTIFY.
JOHN JOINS US LIVE ON THE NORTH
ONE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
IT WAS A FEDERAL JUDGE WHO JUST
RULED A SHORT TIME AGO THAT DON
MCGAHN DOES HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA TO
TESTIFY IN THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS.
THE REASON WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
IS BECAUSE SO FAR THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID THAT HE AND PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR HIM HAVE ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY FROM TESTIFYING BEFORE
CONGRESS.
DON'T FORGET THERE ARE OTHER
SUBPOENAS OUT THERE AS WELL.
THERE IS ONE TO MICK MULVANEY.
THERE IS ONE TO CHARLES
KUPPERMAN, FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL.
THERE COULD BE ONE FOR
JOHN BOLTON.
KUPPERMAN HAS ANOTHER CASE THAT
WILL BE HEARD DECEMBER 10.
IF THIS JUDGE'S RULING THAT
MCGAHN HAS TO COMPLY, THEN
POTENTIALLY OTHER WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE BEEN
SUBPOENAED OR MAY BE SUBPOENAED
MAY HAVE TO COMPLY AS WELL, AS
THAT GOES TO THE NEXT PHASE.
IF MCGAHN TESTIFIES, IT'S LIKELY
THAT HE WOULDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH UKRAINE
BECAUSE MCGAHN LEFT A LITTLE
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO.
PAT CIPOLLONE HE IS THE CURRENT
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL WHO WOULD BE
READY IN ON EVERYTHING DEALING
WITH UKRAINE BUT DO NOT FORGET
THAT MCGAHN TESTIFIED BEFORE
ROBERT MUELLER IN THE
ROBERT MUELLER RUSSIAN INQUIRY
FOR SOME 30 HOURS AND HAS AN
AWFUL LOT OF INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN REGARD TO
RUSSIA AND POSSIBLE COLLUSION.
AND WHAT POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE MUELLER WAS ALLUDING
TO IN HIS REPORT.
STILL A LOT MORE TO COME ON THE
POTENTIAL FALLOUT FROM MCGAHN
HAVING TO TESTIFY AND EXACTLY
WHO HE WILL TESTIFY TO.
THE HOUSE AND SENATE ARE NOT IN
SESSION THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE OF COURSE OFF FOR
THANKSGIVING RECESS.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
IS BUSY WRITING UP ITS REPORT
THAT IT WILL SUBMIT TO THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY TO SEE WHERE THIS ALL
GOES NEXT.
FOR ITS PART, THE WHITE HOUSE
WENT TO THE DOGS TODAY, ONE VERY
BRAVE FOUR-FOOTED SPECIAL
OPERATOR.
>> CONAN CAME OVER FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INTRODUCED
THE NATION TO CONAN, THE BELGIAN
MELON
LAW >> CONAN DID A FANTASTIC JO
JOB.
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE CONAN.
>> CONAN WAS SERIOUSLY INJURED
WHILE CHASING AL-BAGHDADI INTO A
TUNNEL.
THE DOG NEARLY ELECTROCUTED WHEN
HIT BY EXPOSED WIRING.
>> CONAN WAS VERY BADLY HURT, AS
YOU KNOW.
THEY THOUGHT MAYBE WAS NOT GOING
TO RECOVER.
RECOVERED QUICKLY AND HAS SINCE
GONE ON A VERY IMPORTANT RAID.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO WITH
IMPEACHMENT ON HIS MIND,
TWEETING TODAY THAT SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHMENT IS DROPPING LIKE A
ROCK, DOWN INTO THE 20s AND
SOME POLLS.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHERE THE PRESIDENT
CAME UP WITH THAT NUMBER, THE
FiveThirtyEight.com AVERAGE HAS
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT AT
45.6%.
OPPOSITION HAS REGION TWO POINT
POINTS.
SOURCES CONFIRM TO FOX NEWS
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
PAT CIPOLLONE IS LOOKING AT
INTERNAL COMMUNICATIONS
REGARDING THE HOLD ON AID TO
UKRAINE.
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION BETWEEN
ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF
MICK MULVANEY AND THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET REGARDING
THE LEGAL ASPECTS OF IMPOUNDING
THE FUNDS WHICH MAY HAVE
REQUIRED COURT ACTION.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE
CONTINUES TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
MULVANEY.
>> DO YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
MICK MULVANEY, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> I DO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE AN AN AB
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE AN AN AG
THUMBS-UP TO TO RUDY GIULIANI.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS HAVE ISSUED
SUBPOENAS THAT SUGGEST THE
INVESTIGATION INTO LEV PARNAS
GOES BEYOND CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION TO POSSIBLE MONEY
LAUNDERING AND OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
AND THAT PROSECUTORS MAY BE
LOOKING CLOSELY AT THE WORK OF
GIULIANI HIMSELF.
>> THE STRONGEST MAYOR, THE BEST
MAYOR.
RUDY IS A GREAT CRIME FIGHTER.
I THINK THAT MAY BE THE PRESS
ISN'T TREATING RUDY VERY WELL
AND I THINK THAT'S UNFAIR.
>> AND CONGRESS RETURNS FROM THE
THANKSGIVING BREAK, THE RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE PLANS TO SUE CNN AND
"THE DAILY BEAST" FOR REPORTING
THAT HE WAS WORKING WITH
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS WHO TRY TO
DIG UP DIRT ON JOE BIDEN.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES TELLS
FOX NEWS IT'S THE FAKE NEWS
STORY OF THE CENTURY AND HE IS
SAYING HE WILL FILE TWO LAWSUITS
LIKELY IN FEDERAL COURT.
>> TO GO BACK TO WHERE WE
STARTED, FEDERAL DISTRICT JUDGE
RULING DON MCGAHN, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, MUST COMPLY
WITH A CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA TO
TESTIFY IN THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD ANY REACTION
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE SINCE THIS
RULING WAS ISSUED BUT I WOULD
SAY IT'S A FAIR BET THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO TAKE IT
TO THE APPEALS COURT.
>> Bret: THE JUDGE FINISHES
THINK MR. MCGAHN IS LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO TESTIFY, HE'S
ENJOYING, IT SAYS TO APPEAR FOR